[Musique]
jean gabin la légion d'honneur on sait
ce que c'est c'est une grande
distinction honorifique que vous avez
mérité par toute une vie au service de
votre art ce que l'on sait moins et ceux
dont je voudrais parler maintenant c'est
qui est jean gabin alors par conséquent
si vous le voulez bien vos nom prénom
âge et qualité que ben jean gabin alexis
moncorgé votre âge 55 ans passés je vais
sur ma 56e année et
et qualité qu'aux médias mais excellente
jean gabin vous êtes mariés
je suis marié père de famille père de
famille j'ai deux filles et un garçon
trois enfants trois enfants 30% de
réduction famille nombreuse dans les
médias notamment et dans la maison et
dans le très exactement connues est-ce
que vous avez des buts des diables j'ai
débuté en 1922 hiver 22-23 aux folies
bergère car je viens du music hall j'ai
débuté au music hall ensuite j'ai fait
mon tour de chant j'ai joué l'opérette
et jusqu'au jour où je suis rentré au
cinéma c'est à dire en 30 tu ailles voir
francs en
quel a été votre premier film mon
premier film était une opérette
car comme j'étais un jeune premier
d'opérette à l'époque que je chantais je
dansais mon premier film était un film
simple chacun sa chance chacun sachant
chacun se chacun sachant c'est dur à
dire
c'est alors que commence la série de vos
succès c'est-à-dire maria chapdelaine la
bandeira gueule d'amour
la grande illusion entre autres il
faudrait décider tous puis c'est la
guerre que vous faites dans les forces
navales françaises libres
le quartier maître jean moncorgé puis
que vous revenez en france que se
passe-t-il alors j'ai eu une éclipse
j'ai eu une éclipse je vais vous dire
pourquoi je crois le savoir maintenant
parce que j'étais parti tout de même en
pleine forme si j'ose dire je suis parti
à la guerre j'avais donc prendre 5 36
ans oui et à ce moment là je jouais
encore les jeunes premiers je suis
revenu avec les cheveux blancs et ça m'a
donné
ça m'a donné les complexes d'avoir les
cheveux blancs parce que je
je pouvais plus pensé jouer les emplois
que je jouais avant la guerre alors je
me suis cherché un peu j'ai j'ai fait
quelques films qui n'ont pas été très
heureux et puis vous savez le public est
parfois exigeant il voulait probablement
me retrouver comme il m'avait quittée
mais jallet crise en mieux j'avais 10
ans mieux et ses 10 ans et je les avais
physiquement en plus est sur mon visage
alors
j'ai tourné j'ai eu quelques films qui
n'ont pas été très heureux et puis j'ai
tourné un film avec clément qui
s'appelait au delà des grilles qui a été
un succès et puis j'ai eu la grande
chance parce que c'est une énorme part
de chance dit ron dans ce métier j'ai eu
l'énorme chance de tourner touchez pas
au grisbi et touchez pas au grisbi
c'était en quelque sorte une réplique de
ce qu'avait été pépé le moko l'entente
avec 6 euros les 15 ou 20 ans de plus le
film a marché et c'est reparti
mais je vous dis là dedans il ya une
grande partie de chance oui mais il ya
aussi énormément de votre talent jean
gabin et je crois que s'il fallait jouer
en parlant de vous couper s'y colle mais
un beau rôle
ça aide beaucoup un acteur beaucoup
quel est votre violon d'ingres on dit
que vous aimez beaucoup la télévision
c'est exact je vois je vois tous les
soirs la télévision quand je suis chez
moi j'ai une grande joie mais tu mets ça
va te mettre ma petite table avec avec
ma femme on regarde on dîne en regardant
la télévision je vous vois tous les
soirs d'ailleurs mangez le si je
voudrais maintenant à venir à votre
légion d'honneur je voudrait la faire
voir aux téléspectateurs voulez-vous me
tenir mon époux genre très cool merci
voici la croix de la légion d'honneur de
jean gabin
et je ne la connaissais pas vous ne
connaissiez pas un pas du tout fait
jamais vu donc je te nommer jeunes pour
moi je veux dire si j'ai déjà vu les
gens d'honneur mais pour moi non parce
qu'en principe elle n'est pas encore
officiellement j'ai pas reçu diplômes si
j'ose dire bien sûr
qui est ce qui va vouloir m je pense je
pense monsieur le directeur de la
cinématographie monsieur frégant mort et
j'aurais ben la légion de neige c'est
tout de même une étape dans la vie d'un
homme cela prouve que vous avez beaucoup
travaillé que vous avez beaucoup réussi
et en principe elle marque aussi le
début d'une nouvelle étape dans la vie
d'un homme
vous voudriez bien sûr essayer de faire
mieux
on veut toujours faire mieux la
prochaine fois philippe mais je voudrais
vous demander tout simplement de rester
au cours des années qui vont venir vous
même de rester jean gabin
c'est à dire leader à juste titre v du
mic français je remercie l'homme que
chacun va voir avec al avance de
sentiments
plaisir de la voir un hangar landes
merci non ce n'est pas à vous de dire
merci je crois dans la balle
après une telle carrière c'est au public
à vous remercier
prends la liberté de le faire ensemble
eh bien merci quand même et merci pour
le public
[Musique]